hey everyone thanks for tuning in
really appreciate you joining us today
today we'll be talking about get ops in
in the context of git lab and anthos
config management
so really looking to talk about more
detail on how organizations can adopt
git ops the cultural aspect of it with
the right technology tool sets like
gitlab
and anthos my name is mike davramani i'm
a senior alliance manager here at gitlab
and i've had the privilege to work with
many different teams across google to
bring to market how git lab and anthos
are
lowering the barrier of entry into
devops and cloud native best practices
for our customers i'll pass it a theo to
do a quick intro
hi everyone super happy to be here i'm
theo shanley i'm a cloud
solutions architect for google cloud and
i work on
various devops topics and i happen to be
a fairly heavy gitlab user
back to you mayank brilliant so before
we dive into the joint solution let's
talk about the core building blocks
of what we're discussing give a little
bit of context and background
particularly around the core building
block of kubernetes as
a robust platform as a service to manage
all your container workloads
as companies look to move into
microservice based architecture and
containerize our application kubernetes
becomes a de facto platform to deploy to
and as organizations grow and complexity
arises you can imagine
more and more kubernetes clusters across
hybrid or multi-cloud environments
become the de facto norm
so to manage that complexity whether
it's across policy management
networking managing different clusters
all that
complexity can be addressed with anthos
as a solution
anthos is a unified platform it's
managed
applicable for multi and hybrid cloud
environments that are
running kubernetes workloads
particularly with anthon's config
management that we'll be focusing on
today's talk
on how you can manage those policies and
declarative code
to manage complexity across your
different clusters and environments
on top of anthos is gitlab which helps
you provide that workflow management
capability in a single application
for your operators your developers or
your security engineers a single pane of
glassware that can all work
store their code and provide information
concurrently and collaboratively as a
single source of truth
a single devops application that can
help you manage how you operate and
deploy to
across kubernetes clusters using anthos
but that's the technology aspect of it
let's
also talk about the cultural aspect of
it why even go down the route of
declarative
infrastructure declarative code to
operate uh
your your complexity why get offs in
general
really with get offs you get a lot of
reliability once you've defined it and
fully automated the process
you're able to replicate it in a
reliable fashion
the more you software define your
operation the more you software define
your business the less
human intervention that you have to work
with you abstract and
allow humans to focus on the
intellectual contributions
to iterations and improvements versus
having error-prone
processes where different teams are
having to communicate with each other to
asynchronous or different means
that are not automated accessibility
becomes
also another great value proposition of
git ops once it's in git
it's versioned as a source of truth you
can track the change you can
concurrently
collaborate as things are being ported
changed and redeployed you can track
those changes over time using git as a
fundamental protocol and then using
gitlab for the workflow aspect of it
at the end of the day you're using
familiar tools when you're trying to
adopt git ops you're using
kubernetes manifest you're using yamls
that's much more declarative
and explicit you're using ci cd and
merge requests and git lab
and using git allowing more user
personas in the single pane of glass
to operate familiar tools that
developers are already familiar with
today
so let's now dive into the reference
architecture how do we configure git lab
and your repositories to work better
uh to work seamlessly with anthon's
config management
dale do you mind walking us through the
slide yeah
sure thanks mayank so ready here this is
our reference architecture on the right
you have two
google kubernetes engine one staging and
one for production
you of course can have more than that
but that's just our example
and in the center here in that gray box
we have the core of the system which is
gitlab
and we are using gitlab to host three
different git repositories
and the first one that i want to talk
about is the one with in the middle with
the black logo
it's called enforce config management
and that's a git repository that's going
to be
mainly used by the platform teams and
the goal of enforce config management is
to
bring github's approach to configuring
policies
so with that repository when you commit
a conflict to that
repository you will be able to
automatically
apply that configuration or that policy
across all your clusters at once
and because it's in a git repository and
because it's declarative
you can use all the usual git workflows
and git lab workflows that you're used
to such as
merge requests or approvals or ci tests
etc etc etc and on the left
we have two other git repositories that
are used for the last component of this
reference architecture
this last component is application
delivery manager or
app ctl for short which is the name of
the cli
and so we had enforced config management
that's githubs for config and policies
and we have app ctl
that's githubs for applications so the
first of those two git repositories
that's the one with the red logo that's
the application repository
and that's uh that's really a normal
application repository in our case it's
called hello world because i'm a fairly
bad developer
but it's really a normal git repository
where you have your source code
bit java python ruby whatever you want
the only difference is that you have
basically templates for your carbon
kubernetes configurations in that
repository
and in that repository you work as you
would normally and the last
repository is the one with the yellow
logo it's called the deployment
repository and that one is mainly
managed by ab ctl you don't have to
interact with it too much
and the only thing that it contains is
the fully built
kubernetes configurations that are built
from
the templates that are in the first
repository the application
repository and uh
so that that last repository the
deployment one contains those full cuban
configurations for each environment and
uh absolutely is going to apply those as
is
to your different kubernetes clusters
so let's dive into the first of those
components that i mentioned and first
config management
so uh just to preface uh everything
enforce config management is part of
enforce
and is a globally available product
today
so it actually has three different sub
components the first of those is called
config sync
and convincing is uh taking the
configurations and policies and
everything that you have in your git
repository and applying that
to your community clusters and
really it can be any cuban subjects but
we are focusing on
configuring policies and things like our
back holes or
istio tables or
network policies those kind of things
the second of those components is called
policy controller and that's a managed
version of an
open source project called open policy
agent gatekeeper
and policy controller allows you to
enforce policies across all of your
clusters so for example
if you want all your deployments to be
labeled with an
owner label allowing you to identify
which team owns which deployment
then you can enforce that with police
policy controller
you just declare the policy in your git
repository
and every time that the deployment is
going to be created
policy controller is going to be to
allow that creation or not depending
on what you have in your deployment and
the last component that i'm not actually
going to demo today is called
config connector and that makes the link
between
given custom resources and gcp resources
so for example you can have
a cloud sql a custom resource incubators
and config connector is going to create
and manage
for you the corresponding cloud sql
instance in gcp
and between config sync and config
connector
you can have you can declare your gcp
resources in your git repository and
have them created and managed in gcp
so let's move to the next component
which is application delivery
aka fctl so app ctl is not yet a ga
product it's pre-release
it's freely available and we're actively
looking for
user feedback on that product to make it
even even better and even more flexible
for
our further users
as i mentioned previously app ctl really
works with two git repositories on the
left here with the red
red logo we have the application
repository and
it's really a normal application
repository where you're going to develop
you're going to create commits create
branches create merge requests in gitlab
and have a preview on that request from
ci test etc etc
and once that merge request is is
approved
you're going to merge it back on the
main branch
it's called master here and once you
want to release
your application to your various
environments you're going to tag
a specific commit in our case one two
three
at that stage you can run the command
abctl prepare staging
and what that does it looks at your
application repository takes
the last state of that and builds
the full kubernetes configurations for
that
for that version of your application and
create a merge request in the deployment
repository on the right here with the
yellow logo
with that full kubernetes configuration
and because it's a request you can
review it you can
run a ci test in gitlab ci on that on
that merge request
all the normal things and really it
allows you to see exactly what's going
to
be deployed in staging and once you're
fine with that you actually merge that
onto the staging branch
and you're on ab ctl apply staging and
that's actually going to deploy your
application in staging
and you can see that in that repository
on the deployment one on the right
we have multiple branches and we have
actually one branch per environment
one for the staging environment one for
the prod environment and one for
other environments if you have other
environments and the last thing that we
want to do
is promote our application from the
staging environment
to the production environment and for
that we are going to run the command
abctl prepare prod from and staging and
app ctl is going to look at the version
that you
currently have in staging build the full
kubernetes configurations for
prod but with the version used in
staging
and create a merge request for the print
branch that you're going to be able to
review
test etc etc and once you merge that
merge request
you can run appstill apply pod and
that's going to
deploy your application in production
with the same version that you had in
staging
so i know that all of that is a lot to
take in
so i think it's better to look at a demo
and to see how if everything works
together in reality
we are starting with two gk clusters one
for
the production environment and one for
the staging environment
as you can see i have access to my
exchanging cluster in that case with
three nodes
this is the enforce config management
git repository
and in this repository i can define
config and policies
in this particular directory for example
i can
list my clusters and give them labels
this is also where i'm going to define
my namespaces and in our case i'm
defining an hello world namespace
just putting that namespace in that file
makes it appear in my uh
in my cluster as you can see here the
hello world
namespace already exists in my cluster
in that repository
i already have a merge request created
for this demo
and this merge request is going to allow
me to modify
configurations and policies on on that
cluster so for example here the merge
request
is designed to add a constraint a policy
that says that
every deployment in the namespace
helloworld and sem tests
need to have a label called team
and for that merge request because it's
gitlab i can just have a gitlab ci
pipeline and here i have a couple of
jobs that vet
that my configurations is valid
and also that validate that my own
configuration is compliant with
with the policies that i set to change
policies of course you want to make sure
that everyone who needs to approve a
policy change
is going to approve it so in that case
we are using the approval
feature of gitlab to make sure of that
and in that case i just gave myself the
approval permissions
so we are going to merge that and you're
going to see that
our new policy is going to appear in the
cluster fairly quickly
and here it is so until now i
was playing the role of a platformer
newsletter now let's switch and let's
say that i'm a developer
i have this very simple hello world
application that just displays hello
world
potentially with a custom message and
it's written in python and i have a
docker file
everything very normal and i have
a ci pipeline for that for that
application
and i'm going to use app ctl to deploy
that application so i
initialize my project with app ctl
and it's actually going to create a new
project absolute
hello world deployment that's going to
contain my configurations that we're
going to
deploy to my clusters and in my
project now you can see that i have two
new directories
one for uh called delivery and one
called config
i'm now initializing my two environments
for app ctl
so i can start by adding the staging
environment by specifying which cluster
and which namespace i want to deploy my
staging application in
and then i just do the same thing for
the prod environment
once this is done both environments are
going to show up in the delivery
directory
here you can see just the definition of
the production environment
now the config directory is a customized
config directory and you can see that
app ctl has provided the skeleton for my
environments
to make things simpler i'm just going to
copy an existing
configuration and you can see that now
i have a deployment where i don't
specify the
the image type tag and a service
file where i create a lab answer and in
the customization file for my
base configuration i'm going to modify
the
tag that i'm going to use i'm just going
to use video
and i'm referencing the resources
deployment and service
and now for each environment i'm
modifying the message
because i'm giving it a custom message
here you can see for the staging
environment i'm saying hello staging
world
now let's commit tag and push everything
to gitlab
and obviously this is going to trigger a
ci pipeliner
that ci pipeline has several stages
including one with three different tests
and if we look at for example the unit
test
or in this case the linting we are going
to
see that uh gitlab uh detects some
problems with my code
which we don't care too much about right
now
and here you can see the unit tests that
have all passed that
is important but you can see that
there's like a third
third test that hasn't succeeded and
that's the validate stage
and what does that stage do as you can
see we have here
a policy validation the same one that we
saw earlier
where it says that all deployments must
have a team label
and where does that come from it
actually comes from the previous
stage where we downloaded the policies
from the enforce config management
repository
and how do i do that if we take a look
at my gitlab.cieml file you can see that
i
actually include another gitlab.cml file
that comes from the infos config
management so the platform team has
provided me
already with everything that i need to
check that my application
is compliant with their policies
so let's fix the policy evaluation by
adding
this famous team label now
label team team hello world we don't
care too much about
the actual value of the label and now
let's just update the tag
and once again commit tag and push
everything
of course this creates a new ci pipeline
and spoiler alert this one is going to
actually succeed uh while we're waiting
for that pipeline to finish
let's uh use app ctl to actually deploy
instead in the staging environment so
here i'm using the ctl prepare
command and i'm saying that i want to
deploy the tag v0.0.2 to the staging
environment
and what does that do it actually
creates a merge request
on my other repository if you remember
hello world deployment one
so let's take a look at that merge
request
here you can notice that i'm not in the
repository for my application i'm the
hello world deployment
repository that's the one that contains
the manifests that i'm going to deploy
and that merge request is a merge
request to
add the full fully isolated manifest
to uh to this repository and as you can
see here in this manifest i have an
image tag and i have my
custom message and i have both my
deployment and service
in the same thing and you can see that
i'm actually merging into the staging
branch
so abscital uses one branch per
environment
and the name of the branch is the name
of the environment very very simply
so i just merged that merge request
and in parallel the ci pipeline on the
hello world
repository has finished and we actually
pushed the new image to
our container registry and now we just
have to use the abctl apply staging
command to actually deploy our
application to the staging environment
that command is going to take what
exists on the staging branch of the
helloworld deployment repository
and is going to apply it to our cluster
so this apply command takes a little bit
of time but once it's finished
we actually have a new application in
the applications tabs of google
kubernetes engine
here you can see my hello world
application in the staging cluster
for now it's empty but very soon we are
going to see the different components
as just here service and deployment
and you can see that we have like a very
specific version of that application
that is shown and uh if we look
at our hello world namespace uh you're
going to see the lower deployment and
the job that has deployed
that that thing and now we can just look
at
the hello world service and at the load
balancer
this is just a little bit sped up
because we are waiting for the
balancer to come to come command
while waiting for the load balancer to
command we are going to actually
prepare our deployment to production in
that case we are not going to deploy
from
a tag but we are going to deploy from
the staging environment meaning that
we're
going to promote the version that we
have in staging to the production
environment
and it's just the from end parameter
instead of from tank
and like before it creates a merge
request in the hello world
deployment repository in the one that
contains my hydrated configuration
in that case we are going to merge onto
the production branch
the prod branch and not the staging one
and in my fully i written manifest
i'm indeed using the same version of my
application but now i have a different
custom message
so let's merge and in the meantime the
load balancer probably has been created
yes here you can see it with the staging
custom message
now let's apply our newly updated
configuration to the
pod environment and that's exactly the
same process as for the staging
environment
absiil is going to take
the tip of the prod branch in the hello
world deployment
repository and apply it and we're going
to have a new application
in the applications page of gke
and it's going to be exactly the same
thing as for staging
here we have our new application and
let's take a look at the service
for that new application it's of course
in the hello world
uh namespace in the product cluster
and let's refresh to get the actual ip
of the service
and here we have our service with the
production custom message
brilliant theo thanks for that demo now
that we've seen the solution
live and in the demo let's take a half
step back to really
recap some key takeaways really answer
that question why get lab and anthos for
ops as mentioned earlier google and
gitlab are partnering together to really
lower that barrier of entry
into the get off workflows particularly
for those companies that are
standardizing on kubernetes
trying to manage their complexity trying
to software define their
business to be more iterative and agile
as they explore
best practices git becomes a fundamental
building block to kind of
provide that audit trail provide that
coherent cohesity of the single source
of truth
using git lab as a single application
just beyond git
you know with the approval workflows
with merge requests automation pipeline
you get a single application with the
user interface
and user experience for all the
different users and
organization views that are invested in
continuing continually improving the
business
uh through software defined means why
limit declarative management to app and
only infrastructure
you know look into policy management as
well as they are demonstrated with
anthoconfig management use the power of
git to manage your configs and policies
while enforcing
strong security posture really with
gitlab and anthos you get a full
developer experience
full devops experience and a unified
platform you standardize on a single
devops tool a single devops application
on top of an open and unified platform
that your company can adopt quickly
at this point you're probably wondering
well how do you get started where to
begin
great news is we are partnering with
sata and arctic
as channel partners that can help guide
you through that process and really help
you adopt what you saw here today
alternatively we do have reference
material that you can check out offline
we've got two solution guides that are
readily available today
where you can see and read more about
the best practices on how to architect
that application repository that there
was mentioning where you store your
config policies for your multiple
clusters
this is a solution paper that they
actually wrote so definitely check it
check it out to get more finer detail on
how you
you know build up that repository
additionally we've got
another solution paper live now that
helps you and outlines how you can
deploy git lab
on prem on a gke on-prem cluster that
may be managed by anthos
so if you're looking to get started in a
hybrid environment that might be a great
solution paper to check out
additionally we've got a lot of
documentation available as well on
anthony's config management in general
on google stocks page as well as finer
details on the app ctl utility on how to
use it
we've got documentation on git lab on
best practices on what the gitlab flow
looks like how to make
most of merge requests and how to
architect a different
repositories and cicd pipelines for your
use case so you can be flexible and
nimble
we do have supplementary videos to this
session
which have a broader perspective on how
you can use gitlab and anthos in general
so feel free to check that out as well
so with that being said i want to thank
everyone for tuning in
thank you for your time and hope you
enjoyed this session
hope to hear from you soon cheers
you